Look back at your ancestors, look back at your, your grandparents,
look back at what they did, what they lived through,
the seeds that they planted,
that you can afford to be in the circumstance that you are in today.
If you are a black American and you are breathing in the United States today,
you are the luckiest among the luckiest of black people that have ever lived
anywhere on the face of the planet. That is an incredible statement.
All of human history,
the luckiest black people that have ever lived on the face of the human planet
are the ones that are living and breathing in America today. Okay.
If you understand that and you should understand it by simply saying,
where would you like to live in Africa for all of that, that, that,
that hoopla about they took us from Africa,
find me a black American that will tell you they want to move back to Africa.
I will listen right now or Europe.
I'll book the flights for them.
Right? For any person that says we were stolen from our ancestors,
I can assign words in pledging that I will book the flights.
If you were now to us, citizenship for you to go live back in now.
All right, sir.
You're going to books.
I don't have a copy of blackout here because the galleys have not arrived yet,
but the galleys are on the way.
I know that a lot of what we discussed here obviously is what blackout is about.
Um, but what, what maybe did I miss? Or should we, should we hit on?
Or what else?
You know, so blackout for me, it was, I really wanted to first and foremost,
lay out my personal story.
There's been a lot of conjecture about where I came from,
how I became conservative.
Is she a fraudulent conservative and all of that craziness because people don't
realize that I just was apolitical, if anything else.
So to be clear, you're not some sort of secret agent.
You really have been there through all. I've been there since the beginning.
Yeah.
Like digesting my entire life saying she must be a plant. Like,
I mean a Soros plant. And I'm like, I've never even voted.
Like I literally, prior to getting.
Getting into things I had, I genuinely just was not politically inclined. Um,
and I just thought I had to be a Democrat and thought I had to be liberal. And,
you know, looking in the retrospect, I realized how foolish that is. Um,
you know, that I didn't realize that everything was really the,
everything that bad happened in my life was really routed to, uh,
bad policies and bad politicians. Um,
but I wanted to first lay out just my personal story. Um, you know,
the subtitle of the book is how black America can make it second escape from the
Democrat plantations. Um, and I do believe, um, I say this all the time,
people get upset, um, that black Americans are still enslaved today. Um,
that the left just got smarter and they realized that you, you,
you can enslave people, um, their bodies, you can't have black,
black Americans on the plantation anymore,
but you can still have black Americans doing all the work for you and reaping no
benefit.
And that is a structure that we see today between black America and the Democrat
party. We are doing all of the work we get,
we carried them over the finish line and we benefit not in one single way. Um,
and so I really kind of lay out that argument, um, and,
and talk about what slave life was really like, uh, the breakdown of family,
why it was necessary for families to be broken down, uh,
to trade constantly be treating, um, uh, slaves from one plantation to the nut,
to the next they could, they could have no feelings for one another. Um,
at Frederick Douglas, uh, in his autobiography, the first couple of pages,
he started talking about his life as a slave. Uh,
he talks about the fact that when his mother died, he felt nothing. Uh,
when his sisters were treated until he felt nothing, he had no sense of kinship,
no, no familial love, uh,
for his own blood that was necessary to the institution of slavery.
We still have that kinship and that relationship and that community still broken
down all of these years later. But later,
despite the reconstruction era post-slavery, uh,
which we saw black American families getting back together, we weren't,
we were doing something, um, it's all been wiped out.
At a higher rate, by the way, until about 72 or so.
1850S, black Americans were outpacing whites in terms of economic growth. Um,
and then immediately following, you know, the night,
the 1960s and the great society act, um, and, and the systemic oppression,
which started via the welfare system. Everything started falling apart, um, and,
uh, reading another, another topic, uh, talking, going back to slavery, uh,
black Americans, it was illegal for black Americans learn how to read. In fact,
it was so illegal that if you were a white person, you were taught and you were,
and you were caught teaching your slave to read, uh,
you would be found guilty too. It was a serious sin.
The reason for that is because they didn't want black people being educated
because an educated mind can't be enslaved. Well, what's changed now.
Look at the literacy rates in black America today. Look at Baltimore,
look at the inner cities, look at we're in California at California,
70% of black boys could not pass a basic literacy exam.
Nobody's talking about that.
You have politicians that are standing on stage saying that all they care about
is black Americans.
They're not talking about everything that is harming black Americans today.
Everything that is recreating the very same plantations that we can.
Did you catch that brilliant line that Bernie had in one of the debates,
which is he wants, he's not only so pro marijuana, that he wants it to be legal,
but he also wants to have a black community, blacks,
black business owners owning black marijuana shops in black communities.
And again, I say this, I say this as someone that's pro legalizing weed,
but like,
we're going to incentivize black people to own black marijuana shops
in black communities that, that.
Right. And, and, and, but that's, and that's why I don't celebrate by the way,
why I'm conservative on the marijuana front is because when you talk about, uh,
where this is happening, Chicago, I think just passed, uh, you know,
marijuana laws. It is, to me, I know it's,
it's going to lead to more dysfunction, um, you know,
amongst black America first and foremost, because that's how it always is.
You know, it's, it's,
what is it about progressive policies that always leads to progressive results
for the black community first and foremost. And, um, so I,
I am low, uh,
to S to be smart enough to see the debate between, uh, alcohol and marijuana,
so that I can't firmly say Ana, but I have a thinking brain,
and I just don't see how conservatives can make a sound argument against it at
the moment.
What else has to happen for the black community to break? Uh,
I'm going to guess, although I don't have the book yet that at the end,
you're going to,
you either make some predictions or you tell people what tools they need to
really break out of this.
Yeah. You know, it's, it's,
it's not even about making predictions and I have my own personal predictions,
but I definitely am not doing that in the book.
I'm giving black Americans a guide. I'm giving,
giving black Americans and option, uh, the same option, uh,
that I saw before me when I started waking up.
And I'm having this conversation with you, um, you can,
you can have the option to accept this victim narrative, right?
You can have the option to say, I accept this diagnosis of cancer,
even though I feel fine, walk fine and have been living fine my entire life.
I accept that it's terminal illness and I'm going to live like I'm going to die
any moment. Um, or, or you can,
you can develop a different perspective and you can develop a victim mentality.
As I say, forget the victim mentality, develop a victim mentality. Um,
look back at your ancestors, look back at your, your grandparents,
look back at what they did, what they lived through, the,
the seeds that they planted,
that you can afford to be in the circumstance that you are in today.
If you are a black American and you are breathing in the United States today,
you are the luckiest among the luckiest of black people that have ever lived
anywhere on the face of the planet. That is an incredible statement.
All of human history,
the luckiest black people that have ever lived on the face of the human planet
are the ones that are living and breathing in America today. Okay.
If you understand that, and you should understand it by simply saying,
where would you like to live in Africa for all of that, that, that,
that hoopla about they took us from Africa,
find me a black American that will tell you they want to move back to Africa.
I will listen right now, or Europe I'll book the flights for them, right?
For any person that says we were stolen from our ancestors.
I can't assign words in pledging that I will book the flights.
If you were now to us, citizenship for you to go live back.
In Africa,
you want to cap this and maybe a 10 people just in case people were punking.
Yeah. I hate America.
Everyone offered them money and flights. I think you might have done.
You took, nobody took the bait, right?
Because they know America is the greatest place they could possibly live. Um,
and I feel.
Like if someone takes you up on this I'll guarantee one first-class upgrade.
That's amazing. I will do. There you go. Right here. First class upgrades.
You have to renounce your citizenship to America and move and move to Africa.
That's really what you want to do.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.